[Music]
let me tell you something
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
[Applause]
fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
foreign
[Applause]
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
I'll fly away together
into the forever
[Music]
beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it out what
I noticed how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set
tell me something
you can go anywhere
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay and fight to
save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other like
[Music]
it's my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything
completely broke the universe
inside we've been waiting for you
I created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
you're
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
Miss Cara I I'm more Barry
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
[Music]
you that we met my memory's a little
fuzzy
are you still a Nazi
[Music]
we're facing the greatest evil
the world is ever known
[Music]
how are we gonna pull this off
figure it out over a drink
Dungeons and Dragons
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
and if you don't know
ready or not
here I come
cause I'm ready
[Music]
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back
but he doesn't anymore
hey I'm just getting started little bro
I'm coming for everything
[Applause]
don't let him destroy everything you've
built
here I come
we're too high off we can't get down
from here
come on
you're almost here
thank you
this isn't like any other ghost face
what is this place
it's a shrine
guys
we've got a lure him in
we execute them
come on mother scream
it's for you
in theaters March 10th tickets on sale
now
you know when you get a Feeling
until almost 20 years I've never had a
feeling like this you're going to see
exactly what I see this is what
greatness I need the greatest basketball
shoe that's ever been made what's the
plan we build a shoe line around just
him for a rookie who's never set foot on
an NBA court who's a player
Michael Jordan
get Michael Jordan I'm thinking of
reaching out to the parents you talk
directly to the family you're going to
lose your job do you typically show up
at people's front doors unannounced I
was told not to call oh man here we go
every once in a while
someone comes along that's so
extraordinary that it forces change
because they are so very special a shoe
is just a shoe until my son steps into
it
there rated R
exclusive in theaters April 5th
oh
55 exclusively in movie theaters March
10th oh we're the Mario brothers and
plummets again we're not like others who
get all the things
we're faster than the others you'll be
hooked on the brothers
thank you Super Mario Bros it seems like
the only thing you haven't drained is my
bank account
for Super Service call or text Super
Mario Bros Plumbing today at
92955 Mario or reach us on the world
wide web at smbplumbing.com